georgia's lieutenant governor jeff
duncan joins us now to talk about the
election today good to see you again
lieutenant governor let's start
right away picking up on mark's piece
about turnout today there is some
concern that the president's rhetoric
could hurt the turnout today what are
you thinking
well i certainly have been disappointed
about the rhetoric as as you just
mentioned
uh it has not been helpful to talk about
election fraud and
on fan the flames on the misinformation
but i've got to give kelly leflar david
perdue credit they have worked hard
they've been consistently out there
every single day
even in quarantine david perdue has been
trying to work hard to get voter turnout
and so
look we just got to remind georgia
voters to show up and continue to elect
conservatives
that's that's all we can do right now
but what should voters be aware of as
they go to the polls today last night
the president held a rally
again more baseless claims claiming
fraud that it was rigged
he seems to be threatening and bullying
people to really
do his bidding for him what do you want
voters to know georgia voters to know as
they go to the polls today
about their election yeah you know look
here in georgia all eight statewide
constitutional officers are republicans
we've got republican majorities in the
state house and the state senate
and voters have been with us for a long
time i want to just remind them that
conservative leadership is where we're
at here in georgia
and it's our future and david and kelly
have been great uh
great to work with and they've certainly
represented our conservative values
that's what i want to remind them of all
this other sideshow stuff all this
misinformation
uh is not helpful uh it isn't uh it
isn't on message for certain
uh but you know it's the hand we've been
dealt with yes
you called it a sideshow and
misinformation but it's landing for a
lot of people who are believing what the
president is saying
the president has called you out he has
called your governor out
he has made it clear that he's going to
campaign against your governor i know
last time you were here and i keep
thinking about it you mention your three
sons
what are you telling your children
because the children are watching when
the president
of the united states is bullying you
bullying your governor
calling you uh making disparaging
comments
and questioning your integrity what do
you say to your own children at this
point
well it's been a great opportunity in
our own household right i've got
two teenagers and a 10 year old and you
know they get to watch dad come home
who every day tells them hey always do
the right thing it's never
it's never the wrong thing and they get
to watch dad come home and and put that
on display form even if the president
disagrees with me the president
of the united states disagrees with
where i'm at and what i'm doing
but that doesn't mean i'm not going to
do the right thing but it's more than
disagreeing though
lieutenant governor duncan it's more
than disagreeing the president united
states is not being truthful there's a
big difference
between disagreeing and not being
truthful
yeah i think any republican that's using
this election fraud and all this
misinformation and this includes the
president
it's simply just an excuse and it
doesn't help us get to the next level
and to me the next level as a republican
is to try to figure out a way to win
back the white house in 2024.
did the president's phone call cross the
line legally in your opinion
i'm not an attorney so i i don't have
the ability to kind of parse
parse the the differences there but what
i will tell you gail is i was extremely
disappointed
i was extremely disappointed with the
purpose of the call the tone of the call
i can't imagine anybody on the
president's staff was giving him advice
before during and after that that was a
good idea
yeah i was proud of brad raffensberger's
consistent response and
continued to just look for every
opportunity to follow the letter of the
law and certainly that's what he was
hired to do by georgians yeah he has
certainly done that is democracy at
stake some people say it is
well it's certainly not our best foot
forward at this point but you know what
gail this is america and i remind folks
everywhere i go
january 20th i have great news for
republicans the constitution will still
be alive and well
we'll still have the opportunity to
disagree and work against bad ideas
we'll have the opportunity to continue
to figure out ways to get
more you know majorities in other places
and we'll have an opportunity in 2024 to
go back
back up to the plate and take a swing
and see if we can win the white house
back
all right lieutenant governor jeff
duncan thank you we'll all be watching
today
thanks gail